I'm creepy Joe one of the princesses I'm
here to shop you around and make all
your selections for the day
well after a cold open like that we're
all going to have nightmares I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Reuben report it's
June 22nd in the year 2023 little known
fact my due date back in 1976 that's a
long time ago for you kids was actually
June 22nd I was not born until June 26th
that's right this Monday is my birthday
prepare accordingly people we are live
streaming as always on Rumble locals and
YouTube if you want to join us for the
post game show please do at
reubenreport.locals.com we are doing a
Community Q a today you can still get in
some questions on the Fly and a special
welcome to the Reuben report intern
Michaela who is in town in studio right
now maybe at some point we'll have your
hand just come in and you can wave to
the people like the queen last night
guys in case you missed it I was on the
fresh and fit podcast over here in Miami
really great show and I did not know so
these guys they talk about culture they
talk about chicks and sports and just
all the stuff going on in the world
they're here in Brickell in Miami the
really cool studio and I did not know
that they're doing their show not only
on Rumble but on locals like that's the
home of their show so I walk in and
they've got all these all this locals
signage everywhere and they're pushing
everybody to rumble and locals and we
talked about it for a bit and it was
just so great to see that you know this
this fight that I've been on to get
editorial Independence and technological
Independence and everything else that
because I did something that I needed I
had to solve a problem for myself and
how I wanted to go about doing the show
and I was obviously one of the first
guys doing the home studio thing before
everybody was zooming without pants on
and everything else that now there's all
of these people in all of these other
disciplines doing all this other stuff
literally all over the world using some
of the technology that we built so that
was pretty awesome you can catch the
fresh and fit podcast with special guest
Dave Rubin on rumble or locals right now
and quick reminder daverubin dot store
we have relaunched the store new Shirts
Mugs hoodies all sorts of stuff and
today's program people uh you guys know
my feelings about the great Douglas
Murray Douglas is a a spectacular
conservative thinker out of the UK he
actually lives
he's made one mistake in life he he
lives in New York City at the moment I'm
working on getting him to the free state
of Florida he lives in New York City at
the moment it's okay he's having a
little honeymoon with New York City but
nonetheless uh he was on Piers Morgan's
show debating one of these crazy woke
gender Crusaders and it was just a
absolutely beautiful Smackdown and you
know one of the things that I've been
talking about a lot during this pride
month were 22 days in pride month only
eight days left and as I keep saying if
you're genitals are still attached
you're lucky and enjoy them
um one of the things that I keep saying
is that you know the gays have to
separate the G's and the bees and the
L's have to separate from the t's
because there is no movement more
radically against the G's and the B's
and the L's than the t's right if there
was a group of let's say white male
Christians that wanted to chop the
genitals off the G's I'm pretty sure
everybody would be against them but
because it's the tease somehow everyone
and the corporation's in big Tech and
everything else the non profits the ngos
they're all about it this is a problem
Douglas had a beautiful moment on uh on
Piers Morgan's show so we're going to
get to that and then a Reuben report
Community Q a let me talk to you guys
about Old Guard Petco quick and then
we'll get to it guys don't all dog food
companies want to be the best for your
dog well no not really pet food
companies are pushing trendy ingredients
and expensive recipes like fresh and raw
but are they better No in fact most have
no proven health benefits to your dog
also watch as these dog food companies
release bug and vegan recipes it'll show
you where their priorities really are if
you don't want to compromise on high
quality ingredients and want
science-backed recipes real proven
science not fouchy science get Old Guard
it's the only pet food company founded
and run by a PhD in pet nutrition with
quality ingredients like real chicken
egg fish oil and probiotics Old Guard
recipes are perfectly balanced with
guaranteed health benefits and a taste
your dog will love everything including
their resealable bags are made right
here in the United States so right now
go to
oldguardpetco.com subscribe today and
get it delivered right to your door
using Code Dave for a discount with Old
Guard you don't have to compromise
ingredient quality of your dog's health
or your traditional American values buy
for from a company that puts your dog
first and now back to me quick point on
dogs do you know you guys will you guys
remember Emma Emma was my dog before our
dog before Clyde I adopted Emma
it was uh I think 17 years ago today it
was June 22nd 2006 she was a Survivor
from Hurricane Katrina in New Orleans
they sent the dogs all over the place
she gave birth in a box during the
hurricane uh she wasn't able to be
adopted the hurricane was in August of
2005 she was so sick for about seven
months they could not release no more
than seven months about nine months they
couldn't release her finally she was
able to be adopted in June of the
following year and we got her 17 years
ago today I missed that beauty all right
let's talk about Douglas Murray and the
destruction of the woke check out this
clip this is Douglas Murray on Piers
Morgan uh going after a woke cult
ideologue who was claiming that Douglas
is a mean mean man
a fallacy which has been propagated by
gender ideologues and is doing profound
damage to gay people among others in our
society as well as women
very quickly let me explain very quickly
why I can't quite hear you I can hear
you muttering something let me quickly
explain why a poll that just got
published in the United States showed
that among the general population
support for gay marriage has been
starting to decline in the last year why
is that it's because the arguments that
actually brought about liberal rights
for all minorities in last few decades
have started to get turned on their head
and turned against people what is the
source of that it is the gender ideology
movement what is the tripwire for the
general public it is children it is
people learning that their children are
being taught nonsensical things it is
being seen by The Wider public most of
whom are heterosexual and don't need to
identify as assists or anything else it
is being seen from that Vantage Point as
the lgbtqia plus movement losing control
of itself and so a backlash is starting
and the backlash is coming because
people are lying to children and are
using children for medical experiments
there's nothing funny about that there's
nothing that should cause levity in that
it should be treated by adults seriously
yeah I mean Douglas he's just one of the
best who says it better that that
perfect queen's English is it the
queen's English or The King's English
it's the queen's English right I think
it's the queen's English the king
probably spoke it to
um but there's a point here you know
years ago you could probably find an
interview I've interviewed Douglas maybe
a dozen times I think he's probably been
on the Reuben report more than anybody
else uh but you can find an interview of
mine and Douglas from probably uh the
fall of 2016 and he said a line that I
often quote which is that one day The
Barbarians will be at the gate and we
will be debating which gender pronouns
to call them that's what he was saying
you know seven eight years ago and that
is what is happening right now we are
watching communism socialism Marxism
collectivism all of this stuff Usher in
and we're debating gender pronouns and I
love that he makes a point you know I
try to do things with a little bit of
levity here but he has a way of saying
things in a very direct clear serious
manner that this is actually deeply
depressing what these people have done
they have took taken of movement that is
just movements for equality are just
movements to free the slaves are just
movements to have black people vote or
women vote or gay people to get married
movements that are of equal with the
goal of attainable equal rights so
everyone that is legally here as part of
the United States in this case is
treated equally under the law that is
just that's what liberal movements used
to be for but they could not leave well
enough alone right and that's why the
second gay marriage happened the
activist class the average gay person
was like okay
wow we did it we're good we could
let's go be human beings like everybody
else but the activist class the people
the non-profits glad the HRC all of
these organizations and by the way you
can do the racial version of this what's
Al Sharpton doing every day all the race
hucksters they can't let it alone right
because they have to keep raising money
by making you think everyone's racist or
in this case everyone's homophobic or
every anything else so the the lgbtqi
Elemento P Squad they need more of this
nonsense and then they started turning
it on kids right suddenly you've got to
be able to have a guy dressed as a puppy
at a public
parade you know basically twerking in
front of a kid and that's supposed to be
okay and we all know that it is not so
Douglas beautifully lays that out the
woman kind of jumps in and then Douglas
smacks her down just a bit more enjoy
so Douglas it's really important
actually all of that point that you've
just brought up it's very on brand for
you because you know you like to stoke
fear you've actually made a career out
of it we are you know I'll take you back
to your book The Strange death of Europe
and you made a big fright you know you
frightened the entire public about your
thoughts on Europe and we ended up in
brexit you weren't the sole contributed
to that but you were a bigger you can't
see the Ridiculousness in that argument
I can't help you no the bigger issues
there's no such thing as gender ideology
we all have gender identities you
identify as a man and I fully respect
you well no no hang on I don't identify
as a man I was born a biological yes
that's where this whole thing is okay
Douglas uh very quickly I I don't know
Ava anything about your career
um I don't know if you have one but you
did try to imply that you knew something
about mine and you just showed you know
nothing about it because actually my
2017 bestseller the strange death of
Europe was not about the EU so you
should learn at some point to read more
than the titles
commenting
he's just like he's just absolutely
fantastic first off I love the the other
guy who of course was on the same side
as a woman I'm not even sure who that
was but turning to peers like trying to
throw him a bone like you you identify
as a man appears like well I am a man
but that's the whole point of how
ludicrous this thing is because if peers
had then said you know what I've been
thinking about it while we're sitting
here I've enjoyed this debate I'm
actually a woman the guy would have had
to acknowledge that he was a woman
because that's how stupid this whole
thing is right if you feel like a woman
on any given day I'm a cat today all
right get him some kitty litter like
it's so absolutely insane and you can
also see the way they try to link
everything together right so because
Douglas has a certain position based in
biological reality when it comes to the
Sexes uh somehow she can also kind of
Link him to the fact that he's a
xenophobe because he was for brexit and
he doesn't like immigrants or something
it is just absolutely insane but I want
to link that to something that happened
right here in the United States
yesterday there was a Senate hearing it
was called protecting Pride defending
the civil rights of
lgbtq plus Americans again that acronym
is completely ridiculous these letters
have nothing to do with each other but
okay let's put that aside you guys all
know Riley Gaines Riley Gaines is the
incredible female swimmer who was
basically the number one swimmer in the
entire country until Leah Thomas who is
a guy who has a penis which as Connor
often points out he uses as a propeller
for extra speed when he's swimming uh he
then became a girl and started beating
Riley and all the other girls in these
swimming races Riley has just about had
it she has become an incredibly
outspoken voice against boys and girls
swimming which something 10 years ago we
all know we all would have agreed with
uh here she is at the Senate hearing and
it's uh it's rather extraordinary
in addition to being forced to give up
our Awards and our titles and our
opportunities
the NCAA forced me and my female submers
to swim to share a locker room with
Thomas
at six foot four 22 year old male
equipped with and exposing male
genitalia
let me be clear about this
we were not forewarned we would be
sharing a locker room
no one asked for our consent and we did
not give our consent
and I'll I'll set the scene assuming
locker room is not a place of modesty
you're undressing you're fully exposed
and we were forced to take off our
swimsuit in front of a man who was doing
the exact same thing
if nothing else
I truly hope how you can see this as a
violation of our right to privacy and
now some of us have felt uncomfortable
embarrassed and even traumatized by this
experience
I know that I don't speak for every
single person who competed against Leah
Thomas but I know I speak for many
because I saw the tears I saw the tears
from the 9th and 17th Place finishers
who missed out on being named an
All-American by one place and I can
attest to the extreme discomfort in the
locker room when you from these 18 to 22
year old girls when you turn around
and there's male eyes watching in that
same room and I can attest to The
Whispers And The grumbles of anger and
frustration from these girls who just
like myself had worked our entire lives
to get to this meet
and I can attest to the fact that around
the country these female athletes who
opposed the inclusion of Leah Thomas in
the women's divisions were threatened
intimidated in emotionally blackmailed
into silence and submission
you know that girl is a true hero you
know a hero is not necessarily somebody
who wants to be a hero from day one a
hero is someone who along the journey
something happens and then they choose
to walk into the fire and that's what
she is this is a girl who committed her
life to being the best swimmer she could
be happens to be a female so you compete
against other females do you think if
you would have asked Riley Gaines three
years ago uh would you like to be or do
you think one day you will be testifying
in front of the Senate because there
will be a guy in the locker room who
will be beating you and swimming she
would say you're completely insane
everyone would have said that was
complete Insanity and yet here she is
fighting it and you know what's
happening to her right now the
mainstream media corporate press blah
blah blah she's now far right she's an
evil conservative she also happens to be
supporting Governor DeSantis for
president because he's actually fighting
against that stuff in Florida so you
know obviously she's very scary because
of that anyway this hearing continued
and now let's take someone on the other
side of this debate this is Kelly
Robinson who identifies as the first
queer black president of the Human
Rights Campaign and here she is
defending dudes in girls Sports
has a physical advantage in sports over
a biological female not as a definitive
statement
give me an example well no I I don't
think
how many female members of the NBA do
you see well I can say that you know
there's been this news article about men
that think that they could beat Serena
Williams in tennis right that they think
that they could actually score a point
on her and it's just not the case she is
stronger what's your experience been
male female both Serena and Venus lost
to the 203rd ranked male tennis player
which they're phenoms for women my
experience my husband he swam at
University of Kentucky as well in terms
of accolades and in terms of national
ranking I was a much better swimmer than
him he could kick my butt any day of the
week without trying
okay so here you have the black queer
head of the Human Rights Campaign saying
that Serena Williams could beat men in
women's uh beat men in tennis right just
if you put a woman against a man in
tennis it took us about 10 seconds to
find this video which we've shown you
before here's Serena Williams on females
versus males in tennis
well actually it's funny because Andy
Murray he oh he was been joking about
um myself and him playing a match and
I'm like Andy seriously like are you
kidding me because for me tennis and
men's tennis and women's tennis are
completely almost two separate Sports so
I'm like if I were to play Andy Murray I
would lose 6060 and five to six minutes
maybe 10 minutes because no it's true
it's true completely it's a completely
different word the men are a lot faster
and me and um they they get they serve
harder they hit hard it's just a
different game and I love to play
women's tennis and I I only want to play
girls because I don't want to be
embarrassed I would not do the tour I
wouldn't do Billie Jean any justice so
Andy stop it yeah we're not gonna I'm
not gonna let you kill me I'm with you
when it comes to tennis I only want to
play girls
[Laughter]
all right that's a good line Letterman I
miss him
um look there you have arguably the
greatest female tennis player saying
it's not even the same sport men are
stronger they serve faster they hit the
the ball harder like it's obvious
everyone knows it and people always go
when is this thing going to end right
like what is rock bottom with this thing
and I'm telling you there will be a rock
bottom and my guess is it's going to be
something like this there is going to be
a 37 or 38 year old washed up because 37
38 you're washed up if you're an NBA
player male basketball player I'm
talking somebody who's probably six
eight 280 scoring two points a game
never particularly good but you know
size wise could just make it to the NBA
he's going to retire and he is going to
suddenly give himself the name Angela
and he is going to score 35 points a
game grab 12 rebounds and eight assists
a game in the WNBA and they will Crown
the WNBA MVP
a guy named Angela that is how this
thing will eventually implode but you
you see how insane it is the woman and
the women I should say so on one hand
Riley on the other hand Serena the women
that have to face off against men they
know reality but the activist the
activists want to rejigger everything
the way they want it to be uh organized
and that really is the problem here it
is a bunch of people against reality and
once again to quote the great Douglas
Murray The Barbarians will be at the
gate and we will be debating what gender
pronouns to call them all right we got a
Reuben report Community Q a on the other
side let me talk to you guys about Birch
gold group real quick uh you guys know
the Congress once again allowed itself
to be pushed into an appeasing or to
into appeasing the administration into
raising the debt ceiling for the 79th
time Paving the way for continued
Reckless spending and further
devaluation of the dollar as our
national debt continues to Skyrocket how
are you protecting your savings well
Times Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with Birch gold
here's the easiest way to do it Birch
gold will help you convert an existing
Ira or 401K into an IRA in Gold you
don't pay a penny out of pocket pocket
and as bricks Brazil China India uh and
South Africa band together against the
dollar more and more central banks are
diversifying you know what they're
buying yeah gold follow their lead visit
birchgold.com Dave for your free info
kit on gold there's no obligation just
information with an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau and thousands
of happy customers Birch gold can help
protect your savings too visit
birchgold.com Dave do it take action
today and now at
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
and I want to welcome all of the new
annual subscribers we did a massive
giveaway cleared out the closet from the
old merch and a whole bunch of you are
getting t-shirts and a bunch more
welcome to everybody uh here we go Tommy
says Tucker's getting 30 plus million
views in 24 hours on Twitter the
question is yes media is changing and I
see the end of Legacy Media how long do
you think this is going to take how will
it manifest itself podcasts or shows
like the rising will there ever be a
news show without bias on Twitter or
locals that are powerfully educating and
not indoctrination to any side well let
me just be very clear on the locals and
Rumble side we welcome everybody so you
want to come on you want to be a crazy
Lefty you want to be on the far right
you want whatever you you want to be a
moderate you want to whatever you want
to do we just give you the tools to do
whatever you want you want to create a
subscription uh a system for your
network or Channel that's what locals
does you want to get it out there and
get distribution that's what Rumble does
so that's on one side as far as the the
collapse of mainstream media I mean look
we've been seeing this forever our
numbers on this show if you add up
but at the end of the day right now
usually we have you know like on an
average day we'll have about 200 000
views on our full live stream on YouTube
usually about 150 on Rumble so that's
about 350 there are some days where it's
cumulatively over a million some days
it's a little bit less but our numbers
on our our long live stream that we do
every day at 11 o'clock as you know as
you're watching it right now uh we are
now beating basically every certainly
every Show on MSNBC we're beating every
show pretty much on CNN we're beating
many of the Fox shows and fox had one
standout show that one standout show was
Tucker in terms of news right the
Gutfeld nightly show is is crushing it
absolutely that's a little bit of a
different situation
um they have decided they didn't want to
go that route we'll find out a little
bit more why they're obviously in this
lawsuit with Tucker and he's fighting
them right now I think the reason that
he's not on Rumble is for contractual
reasons they're able to keep him off of
purely video site and he's you know
using some legal loopholes to get on
Twitter but they're fighting that out in
the in legal uh in the legal battle at
the moment
um I think basically what's going to
happen is that the mainstream media is
pretty much like a wounded animal in the
corner right now it's wounded it's going
to die but it will lash out relentlessly
as it as it does that's why for all the
people that CNN fires right they got rid
of stelter they got rid of Don Lemon
they got rid of Chris Licht who is the
new CEO to turn the thing around as many
people as they fired they're not turning
it in the right direction it's too late
the New York Times is not suddenly going
to be like oh I guess we did lie about
everything for the last couple decades
maybe we should fix it Washington Post
they're all in on the thing so they
basically have to run out the clock I
don't know what that means exactly but
they're just not going to turn around so
I think the best bet for for you
watching this is if you think I'm doing
a decent job you keep tuning into this
show if you like Shapiro if you like
Crowder if you like someone on the other
side you just keep supporting the people
that you think are doing something
roughly close to the truth and uh and
yeah the danger of course is that we'll
all kind of go off in our own different
ways we'll never agree on what is true
it's one of the reasons that I've been
hitting Trump the last couple days right
like these attacks on Florida when he's
going after DeSantis and New York was
better on covet and calling him lock
down Ron and everything else it's like
we all know it's he knows it's
he's not convincing anybody but
a certain amount of people just go along
for the ride and and I think that long
term that becomes dangerous for the
country the truth is the truth and and
we need to be able to know what the
truth is uh Tony says how many countries
have you visited and which was your
favorite I'm up to 14 myself with
another two to three in the works this
year you know I'm probably around 14 or
so maybe it doesn't no it's got to be a
little bit more of that with Jordan
I did a whole bunch of countries because
we did all the Nordic countries and I've
done UK and I've done Italy and I've
done Egypt and I've done Israel and I've
done Hungary in Canada and Mexico
and yeah so it's somewhere around there
what was my favorite what was my
favorite country well I would say the
the best moment you know when I was
bouncing from country to country with
Jordan
um the best moment I can't say this is
my favorite country overall but the best
moment was going to Sweden where we did
two shows because uh the first show sold
out in literally two minutes and we were
like holy cow what's going on here so we
added a second show and you know Sweden
which is an absolutely it's a beautiful
country and the people are beautiful and
it's very clean and all that it was it's
having problems with immigration and
everything else they have a real
political correctness problem there and
to go there and talk to the people it
was actually uh one night after the
second show I was doing meeting you know
Jordan would do his meet and greet and I
would do a meet and a separate meet and
greet if people wanted to chat with me
after and it was so packed we'd like
several hundred people that I said you
know we got to get out of here let's
just all go to a restaurant together we
all went to a restaurant and there were
there were philosophers and Swedish
famous Swedish Comedians and authors and
all of these people and we just we just
talked for hours and hours that night it
was just a an absolutely wonderful night
uh Jen says have you commented on the AI
generated photos of trump and fauci that
came out a week or so ago from the
DeSantis campaign Tim Poole brought it
up and unless I missed it it's just sort
of failed away without comment so yeah I
think I mentioned it briefly on the show
maybe a week or so ago on it wasn't a
campaign ad on the rapid response uh
DeSantis Twitter account they put up a
video of trump and fauci Trump praising
fauci which was not manipulated and then
they did put up I had to watch the video
twice to even see what they had done
because I watched it and I was like why
is everyone freaking out about this
there was a there was two or three small
pictures of trump hugging fauci that
were not real they were AI now we let me
just say this first off they shouldn't
have done it they shouldn't have done it
everyone's going to do it does Trump lie
about everything sure but like you can't
AI is so dangerous the you know that we
are going to so manipulate images and
voice and video and everything else that
it is just a dangerous path to hell that
we're probably going down one way or
another when people will no longer know
speaking of Truth when people will no
longer know what's true one way or
another they put it up they got hit hard
for it I don't think that they'll do it
again I didn't feel the need to make a
big deal about it because again the
other side's lying about pretty much
everything they they this was a very
like my it really was minor in that if
you watch the whole video it didn't it
didn't change what the truth of the
video was that Fouch that Trump gave
fouching an award on the way out that he
repeatedly praised him and everything
else if they had used AI to manipulate
the truth in a way then I would have hit
them harder on it but for sure it was it
was a mistake and and you look you open
that Pandora's box of AI and you better
be very careful because what comes out
could really come to bite in the butt uh
snow baby says as an employer what are
some things that you value greater than
potential profit I've always felt that
employers should consider the safety of
their employees one of their priorities
the bottom line is important I know you
I know you drug your team from the oh I
know you drug your team from the
dumpster fire of California yes I did
save all you people from California
um you know I always say to my guys I I
don't want to grow just for the sake of
growing you know what I mean like I
there's always ways that we can figure
out how to grow the show and then I can
hire more people and we can grow the
show and I can hire more people and
everything else one of the things that
I'm very proud about here is we have
never believe it or not we have never
put a dime into advertising on this show
so if you watch all of the shows that
are our comps everybody puts a ton of
ads into YouTube and all that stuff we
have never put a dime every bit of our
growth has been completely organic and
that was sort of a for me it wasn't that
I didn't want to spend the money on that
it was just like all right so I put more
money into the advertising we get more
viewers now I hire more people then I
put more advertising in we get more
viewers I have more people like it just
seemed like let's just keep doing
something that's nice and tight and trim
um I'd say the most important thing when
you have a team like this uh is that you
want everybody to feel fulfilled and
rewarded so my policy on work as I
always tell the guys it's like as long
as you do your work I don't care when
you do it or how you do it but we have
an incredibly incredibly tight team now
nothing ever slips through the cracks
like you know we just like I know my
guys are going to show up in the morning
I know I'm going to wake up every
morning and my rundown with Phoenix is
going to be ready to roll and we work
through it and then it happens I know
when we're doing the show that Connor
running the board is going to get to the
right videos at the right time putting a
lot of pressure on you today Anything
Could Happen uh and and we just know
that it's all going to work so I think
just making people feel like they're
valued and important and and I'll feed
you guys on Saturday we're gonna have a
big birthday party I'm gonna feed you
probably filet mignon but we we shall
see David says while I understand the
support for governor DeSantis I fear
this Republican Civil War is just what
the Dems wanted how do you think
DeSantis wins the general without Maga
how does either candidate win with a
split base well first off
I think that whoever the nominee is most
of the people will come around right
I'll look am I supporting DeSantis yes
am I pissed that Trump even this morning
again with this Florida nonsense and the
covet that he keeps doing this yes will
I vote for Trump if it's Biden against
him obviously and I think that's the way
most people feel it just there's a
there's a primary and you fight it out
in the primary that's just kind of how
it is so I think uh it's a it's a key
piece of this to make sure that you're
not burning everything down that's why I
think the lies out of the Trump side are
so dangerous because you don't when you
say okay Rhonda Sanchez is a rhino and
he Soros back then he's friends with uh
Paul Ryan and uh Karl Rove and all that
it's like these are literally made-up
Fabrications they're made up
Fabrications and especially on the covid
stuff it's completely counter to reality
but you're telling a certain set of your
people that and they're gonna believe it
and then they're not going to vote I'm
fairly certain that 99 of The Descent to
supporters at the end of the day if it's
Trump especially the Floridians if it's
Trump and then DeSantis stays the
governor of Florida they'll vote for him
and then that's how it'll be for me like
at the end of this people like Dave
you're going to come crawling back to
Trump but Mike look first off I think
it's important to fight for what you
think is right right whether I agree
with you or not if you're fighting for
what you principally believe is right
then that's good and at the end it's
just politics so if my guy loses this
one and and Trump becomes president
that's fine what we don't want is Joe
Biden to be president again what we
don't want is Kamala Harris we don't
want Gavin Newsom that's the bigger
issue so you just got to remember
uh primaries get nasty don't forget
literally literally during the 2015
primary Donald Trump said that Ted
Cruz's father killed JFK okay that was a
lie it did not happen Ted Cruz ended up
being one of Donald Trump's biggest
supporters so it's like politics is very
weird it makes strange bad fellows I I
think most of that stuff will work
itself out uh Matthew says do you still
talk to Candace Owens uh I asked because
she moved further to the right you know
I haven't spoke to her much lately we
did trade a phone call uh two or three
weeks ago she had said something that I
just wanted to clarify with her one of
the things that I'm not a fan of doing
is especially if I'm friends with
somebody uh if they say something that
I'm that I don't agree with or whatever
I'm not just going to blatantly go after
them without reaching out to them
privately so I did send her a text put
in a call missed her then she called me
I missed her we just haven't been able
to connect
um but look again as I just said so
Everyone's entitled to their own uh
political beliefs I believe that
friendship uh as a general rule is more
important than politics it's why when as
the DeSantis Trump thing heated up I
went out of my way to text Junior and
say hey I hope we're good to go and you
know we'll see what happens after this
he immediately responded that we are
we've been friends for over a decade
same thing with Ivanka texted her and
immediately she responded and uh and
that is the weird thing about being part
of this it's like your allies with
people one day and then seemingly you're
in opposition and it can start getting
real nasty but like if you realize there
are more important things
about being a human than than just
winning in politics I think you'll be
okay uh Pratt says fox now has many ads
from BlackRock follow the money I also
spotted an anti-oil Sans ad being from
Alberta definitely caught my attention
uh follow the money has Fox been bought
out so fox has a lot of ads from
BlackRock I didn't know that
specifically so I'll take your word for
it but I can't I can't verify that just
on the Fly have they been bought out
look it's a little hard to see to tell
what's going on with Fox you know they
lost the Dominion lawsuit which was
about the election and all that stuff it
was about 800 million bucks and then
obviously what was it two weeks later uh
Tucker it was out over there Dan bongino
was out soon after or was it or maybe
bongino was out just a few days before
if I'm not mistaken
anyway so it's hard to tell uh what
exactly is going on there what I can
tell you from from my uh back and forth
with the fox people is we get emails
every week would you like to do this
show that show the other show I always
say the same thing as long as it's live
and I'm unedited I will go on the shows
so you know lately I've been doing Dana
Perino a lot I do some of the other
shows I'm not doing the even people
always ask why aren't you know used to
do Hannity all the time I was on uh
Tucker and the more of the evening shows
I don't do them just because my life has
changed now obviously with kids like I I
just don't want to be in studio it was
easier when I was on the west coast
we're here now and I didn't have kids
where now I have kids like I just don't
want to be in studio at seven o'clock
like we're either putting them to bed or
I just want to be around a little bit
more so it's much easier for me I'd
always rather do something from like 7
A.M to say 5 p.m something like that so
there's no Grand conspiracy there but my
personal policy on Fox which was would
be even if CNN called me now and CNN has
never called me we've tried to get on
many times over the years I don't try
anymore and even if MSNBC if you will
put me on unedited and live that's it
those are my obligations those are my
those are my requests then I'll do it
um but so I can't speak to what's going
on on the advertising side I don't know
uh tallway says I've noticed you haven't
had much to say about the Lost submarine
that went after the Titanic rather than
asking your thoughts about the sub and
the passengers itself I'm more curious
as to your thoughts on the reactions and
responses to this crisis and do you see
this as part of the degradation of
society through social media so for
those of you that haven't paid attention
to this you know this is the story that
everyone's been talking about these last
few days there was this Expedition by a
billionaire and a few other people to go
see some of the remnants of the Titanic
and now the ship that they went on the
submersible has disappeared there is
Operation right now trying to find them
but but Phoenix was telling me right
before we started it sounds like at this
point they've most likely run out of
oxygen and died what you're referring to
there Tollway is that the media's react
action to this and social media's
reaction like people joyfully uh you
know celebrating that a billionaire died
or how stupid these people were I mean
it's all just gross but you know social
media just does gross things with
everything but I think we have this one
headline I did I saw this this is truly
Beyond imagination like I actually my my
quote tweet of this was I'm actually
speechless this is from the new Republic
look at this headline
Ocean Gate CEO missing in Titanic sub
had history of donating to GOP
candidates
what the high hell does that have to do
with anything
what does that have to do with anything
are you celebrating this man's death and
the death of the other people on board
and there was a 19 year old because this
guy may or may not have voted or
supported or given money to Republicans
like how freaking Twisted could you
possibly be
it's just incredible but yeah you just
see awful things on social media all day
and partly why I try not to be on
Twitter on the weekends and I just hang
out with you guys on locals and post
food and pictures of the kids and that
sort of thing and it's why I do the off
the great August I think it just keep it
keeps me fresh and you know
that's it uh Quinn says if I'm not
mistaken Dave's birthday is next week
how are you celebrating beef fish pork
or chicken all of the moink options uh
so my birthday is on Monday we're having
a team dinner for everybody here on
Saturday and I'm trying to decide what
to do it it kind of depends on the
weather you know Florida this time of
year you can just get crazy storms later
today I'm going to try to get to the
place where I get my big ass briskets we
may do some filet mignon if they don't
have a brisket that I like but if I can
get a nice like 14 pound wagyu brisket
I'll put that on it like I'll try to put
it on about six in the morning and we
could eat about seven o'clock at night
Let It Go for about 12 hours and knock
that out and uh you guys you guys eat
meat Michaela you eat meat meat okay
everybody's gonna eat some meat uh we'll
see I don't think we have any we have no
vegetarians on this team that would be
my red line in terms of hiring I am not
going to have one of those soy boy
freaks on this team okay
um so yeah it will it will be red meat
related I promise you that and we'll get
some pictures up of course uh Joe says
in your opinion which religious story
offers the best life advice
you know this is very easy for me
um and because I mentioned it so often
and I've written about it and I I just
think it's the one that is the most
important especially these days as we
have a time of big government and big
Tech it's David versus Goliath the
little guy can beat the big guy
there is a reason that is a biblical
story
that has resonated with people for
literally thousands of years it's not
just that David had the slingshot and
was able to take out the giant right
it's not just that it's that you have a
chance to do something Against the
Machine right like if you really believe
that you might start doing things you
might you might build a company like why
was I like all right everyone was
complaining about big Tech and all these
problems and I was like all right I
guess I'll just start a company locals
and we'll just see what happens well
locals eventually then merge with Rumble
Rumble is now the number one competitor
to YouTube YouTube's the Goliath in this
situation I've really fundamentally
believe that if David can beat Goliath
then Dave can beat Google this Dave so
like if you get that concept I mean
that's that's the purpose of biblical
stories they're not just like like some
of the stories are more fun right Noah
is the kind of fun so he got all these
animals and they built a boat and they
like that's nuts right and it's kind of
fun and if you watch the I actually
thought the movie with uh what's his
name from Gladiator who's the actor uh
uh Russell Crowe I actually thought that
movie was pretty good you know they they
fictionized it a little bit and it has
some sci-fi elements or whatever but the
point of a good story it is is going to
unleash a uh a hidden truth right and if
if you fundamentally believe that and
and I think truth is so fundamental that
when it's released it's like it cannot
be stopped because if you did not
believe that you could beat the big guy
that the little guy could beat the big
guy then then how would how could you go
about and accomplish your dreams how
could you ever have the heroes adventure
or any of that kind of stuff so I think
that for me that's the one that
resonates the most it's like you've
always got a chance but you got to take
that chance right I'm guessing David was
pretty nervous before you know he's
putting the slingshot together going oh
that guy's huge but you know what
one shot he won and then it worked out
he became the king pretty good uh Mike
says hey Dave when today's children are
growing up many of them will be
suffering both physically and
psychologically from current year sex
change surgeries do you think the
Democrats will own the mess they created
or where they'll will there be more
smoke and mirrors like when they lied
and said it was really Republicans who
wanted to defund the police that's a
great analogy and unfortunately yes
smoke and mirrors at what point in the
last 10 years of this craziness has the
left ever said boy maybe we went a
little too far
maybe defunding the police burning down
our cities was a bit much maybe
relentlessly lying about Trump and
Russia collusion was a bit much maybe
calling Brett Kavanaugh a serial rapist
like you know all the stories right like
everything that they lie about
the machine then covers up for them did
you see this clip we could have showed
it on the show today Adam Schiff was on
Anderson Cooper last night and Anderson
Cooper actually did a halfway decent job
of Journalism he basically was like you
know so it all kind of turned out to be
nothing now of course Anderson Cooper
was pushing Russia collusion for three
years but he basically was like you know
it turned out to be nothing uh do you
regret anything and Schiff is like nope
don't regret it we do it all over again
and it's like shift should be
embarrassed shift should never want to
show up at a restaurant again shift
should be living in a cave somewhere
right but he won't he will you know he's
a congressman now he says he's going to
run for Senator and knowing Democrat
privilege he will probably become the
next senator from California right like
that these people fail their way up it's
it's just absolutely extraordinary how
they do it so no I don't anticipate you
know the people who lied and lied and
lied about covid right all the people
who demanded who weeks before were
telling you my body my choice when it
became when it was a woman's right
related to abortion in pregnancy and
that sort of thing suddenly we're saying
no it's not your choice you damn well
better get injected with this
experimental vaccine that's actually not
a vaccine we're gonna have to redefine
the word vaccine because this thing does
not vaccinate which is what vaccines
usually were known to do before the
covid vaccine they they get away with
everything I think the comeuppance that
you're looking for will not be that the
Democrats as a party or the media as an
institution will come around and say
we're sorry we really screwed that one
up I think what's going to happen is
actually going to be something much more
Twisted which is that the generation of
kids right now who are going undergoing
chemical castration and hormone therapy
and being so mentally and physically
abused
when they are adults and when their
parents are now aging out they are going
to send them to some freaking nasty old
age homes there is going to be I mean
I'm not actually kidding on this I think
there's going to be elder abuse that you
cannot imagine these parents have failed
their basic Duty as a human being as a
parent and and they're going to be
sending them to Shady Pines from Hell
there there's going I mean it's you know
it's like I can be glib about it but I
think there's going to be a mass
generational problem imagine if you're
14 right now and your parents allowed
you to do this and now you're 28 and
you're you your genitals don't match and
all of the stuff the psychological stuff
and the drugs and everything else how
angry you would be at those people who
who it was their most sacred duty to
protect you and they did not do it on
top of all the teachers who did it and
everything else yeah so they'll be hell
to pay but it's not going to come from
the Democrats or mainstream media uh
Kathy says uh would you like one of your
sons to follow in your footsteps and
work on the Reuben report you know
that's a good one
well Justin I mean this kid is he is so
first off they're both 95th 95th or 96th
percentile in height and weight they're
huge both of them are absolutely huge
Justin is a beast this kid is climbing
over everything ripping wallpaper
anything he can find anywhere if he like
he's he's eating Clyde's toys I got
Clyde the dog is eating all the baby
toys and the kids eating all the dog
toys it's just bananas downstairs we got
like just everywhere I'm just trying to
make sure that whatever he's climbing on
he's just not going to get too high and
hurt himself he's going to do something
physical in life it's very obvious he's
clearly going to be a great athlete
something like that Luke is just a
thinker this kid just sits there and he
stares at you and he's thinking and he's
very serious and then every now and
again
little smile those because he knows
something's up I don't know what he
knows but you know you see these kids
every now and again you're like he knows
something I'm not exactly sure what it
is so I think he's going to be like a
like a playwright or a writer or an
author or something like that and and
Justin is definitely going to do
something and Justin's going to be like
a ditch digger or he's just gonna do
something physical I can tell but as far
as like working on this I mean look uh
their last names are Reuben somebody's
gonna have to take over when the old man
retires it's going to be like secession
you know what I mean there's just gonna
be a war over who's going to get to host
the Reuben report it'll be uh it'll be
they're going to do a series on HBO we
shall see uh joking aside I just want to
support whatever will will make them
fulfilled and hopefully a little bit
happy but but happiness should not be
the goal purpose should be the goal and
hopefully we'll give them the tools to
do just that Dave says uh just
discovered the improvements in the
locals Apple TV app ah very nice uh
we're now watching on the iPad over
dinner and moved to the Apple TV on the
big screen you look fabulous it even
remembers where we stopped on the iPad
keep up the good work so I've been
telling you you know a lot I know people
are always
uh there's a lack of patience when it
comes to building things but you really
got to understand what we're doing at
locals and Rumble we are building
everything ourselves we are not
Outsourcing stuff we're not bringing in
third parties we the cloud
infrastructure is what Rumble built
itself literally the the physical pieces
uh are owned the like the the hardware
is owned by Rumble there are Cloud
servers all over the place I don't even
know where they all are I'm not even
supposed to know where they all are
because you want Cloud servers in
various places so they can't just be
taken out right like that's next level
Warfare when when the machines take over
and they start blowing up buildings
because that's where the the servers are
that are running the internet that's a
whole other sci-fi Black Mirror
Adventure right there but we are
building everything ourselves so I'm
glad to see that the new Apple TV app is
humming along quite nicely uh we are
working on some call-in features you
know we acquired the call-in app that
David sacks created so I'll be able to
do a live call-in audio call-in show
with you guys which I can't wait till we
incorporate in the app so that will be
something for subscribers so we'll start
doing a new version of the show
or it'll be part of the post game show
or something where you guys can call in
Old School radio Like Larry King when he
would do his TV show and he'd be
interviewing somebody and then they
would take callers uh that were screened
in but we're not even going to screen
them because if you guys pay a couple
bucks I'm gonna trust that you're a
decent human being that cleans up almost
everything uh and we're working on a
whole host of other features I told you
we're working on messaging to messaging
meaning that you guys can message each
other having nothing to do with me once
you're in the app a whole bunch of other
stuff so just just hang tight uh but I
promise you it's all coming it's all
coming uh one more for you if you could
learn this is Elizabeth you could learn
instantly any language what would it be
look I live in South Florida my Spanish
could be better I am working on it a bit
but you know we have so many Cubans down
here so many Venezuelans uh Guatemalans
so many people Spanish is just
ubiquitous down here and if I could
brush up a little bit I could probably
get more of my house projects done
because I got a lot of guys coming in
and I got to do translate and they got
to do translate and it would save a lot
of time so a little um
muy bien a little Spanish very good guys
if you're not subscribed please do so on
rumble.com reubenreport if you want to
join us for these Community Q and A's
join us at
reubenreport.locals.com we've got post
game show coming up for the local
subscribers in just a moment we leave
you with a cold close that I think
you'll enjoy and I'll see everybody on
the other side ah d o switches what is
it goodbye in Spanish
oh boy look at this
okay this looks good very very good
all right and I like what you're wearing
I feel fat oh no you're Stout the camera
loves Stouts look the key word is
tasteful I want you to relax and have
fun because you're a fun guy
Feel the beat
but you know you've got some real strong
pecs but it's hard to tell under that
t-shirt you want me to take it off well
I don't know
it's up to you do you think it would be
better if I did it might be I mean
whatever you want
come on give it to me come on
[Laughter]
oh
God this photo clearly indicates your
involvement in some
ill-conceived mail order pornography
ring as does this one
found in the same disturbing packet
[Laughter]
oh my God
I have a few questions we'd like you to
answer
I have a few questions of my own
[Music]